should we start at the beginning
okay
as a child
were you
good at mathematics like was was
mathematics a natural thing for you
which yeah it was very natural
and i always liked it i like counting
i like continually multiplying things by
two
although by the time i got to 1024 or
whatever it is i was
had enough of it
uh
but uh i like i like math i discovered
as a very young
kid maybe four
something called zeno's paradox you ever
hear of xenos paradox my father told me
that the car could run out of gas
and i was
disturbed by that notion that never
occurred to me but then i thought well
it shouldn't run out you could always
use half of what it has and then you
could use half of that and then half of
that and it could go on forever and so
it would never run out
so now it didn't occur to me yes but it
wouldn't get very far either but
but the idea that in principle you
didn't have to run out of gas was uh
kind of a profound thought for a for a
very little boy did it feel like this
was where your career was going to take
you or were you like another boy who
dreamed of being a a baseball or
something no no no no the only thing i
thought about was i would
be a mathematician whatever exactly that
meant
i didn't know quite what it meant except
that
mathematics was the only subject i
really liked
they wanted me to go to berkeley and get
away from mit meet some new
faculty because i was quite close to the
mit faculty and they thought
i think they didn't want to get rid of
me so much as they thought i was
probably pretty good so i should get
exposed to
a certain guy
named chern
who was just coming to
berkeley that year
and i got this very nice fellowship and
i went there i was very eager to work
with churn me turned except he wasn't
there
he celebrated his first year at berkeley
he had just come to berkeley and he
celebrated that first year by taking a
sabbatical
so he wasn't there
so i worked with another guy which which
was fine
and by the time churn came
in the second year i was
already uh
pretty far along with the with the
thesis project i was giving a seminar at
the beginning of my second year at
berkeley and in walk this tall chinese
guy
and i said to the guy next to me who's
that i said that's churn that's churn i
didn't know he was chinese i thought
churn was probably short for chernowski
or something or he was probably some
polish guy who who would shorten his
name to churn if it had been chen or
chan i would have known it was chinese
but chern with the r i don't know but
anyway so i met chern then and we became
uh friends because i was much younger
than he but we became friends and later
collaborators
so we worked together
and we came up with these results this
whole
structure
in fact there's that's uh
the
slides of the presentation that churn
made in uh at the international congress
in
the early 70s it was very nice geometry
i pushed on with it and we
defined some things called differential
characters which was another chapter
uh with working with a guy named chiger
but
the chern simons invariants about 10
years later
the physicists got a hold of it and it
seemed to
be very good for what ailed them
or whatever what might have hailed them
and so
and it wasn't just string theory
as i subsequently developed it was kind
of all areas of physics including
condensed matter theory
even some
astronomers seem to want to look at
those terms that's really what's great
about basic science in this case
mathematics i mean i didn't know any
physics
it didn't occur to me that this material
that churn and i had developed would
find use
somewhere else altogether this happens
in basic science all the time
that one one guy's discovery
leads to someone else's invention and
leads to another guy's machine
actually in the middle of my mathematics
career which ended when i was about 37
or 38
was that i spent four years at a place
called the institute for defense
analyses
down in princeton which was a
super-secret government
based national security agency based
a place for
code cracking but i also learned
about computers
and algorithms and i did one thing there
that was quite good because i can't tell
you what it was it's all classified so i
had a good career they were both doing
mathematics and
learning about the fun
of computer modeling
my father had made a little bit of money
and i have had the opportunity to
try investing it
and that
was interesting
and i thought you know i'm going to try
another career altogether
and so i went into the
money management business so to speak
so you started
with some of your dad's money and that
got you a taste of an interest in it
some family money and then some other
people put up some money and uh i did
that
uh no models
no models for the first two years so
what were you doing then you were just
using cunning and uh you know just
like normal people do like normal people
do
and i brought in a couple of people to
work with me and uh
we were extremely successful i think it
was just plain good luck but nonetheless
we were very successful but i could see
but this was a very gut-wrenching
business
you know you come in one morning you
think you're a genius the markets are
for you we were trading currencies and
commodities and
financial instruments and so on not
stocks but those kinds of things
and the next morning you come and you
feel like a jerk the market's against
you it was very gut-wrenching and in
looking at the patterns of prices i
could see
that there was something we could study
here that there may be some ways to
predict prices
mathematically or statistically
and
i started working on that and then
brought in some other people
and gradually built models
and the models got better and better and
finally the models replaced the
fundamental stuff so it took a while i
would have thought with your background
and mathematician this would have almost
occurred to you immediately like you
would have straight away saying this
what what was the two-year delay well
two things i saw it pretty early
but
and i brought in a guy who was a
wonderful
guy also from the code cracking place
and he was uh i thought together we'll
we'll start building models that was
fairly early but it wasn't right away
but he got more interested in the
fundamental stuff and he says the models
aren't going to be very strong and so on
and so forth so
we didn't
get very far
but i knew there were models to be made
then i brought in another mathematician
and a couple more
and a better computer guy and then we
started making models which really
worked but you know
the
the general
uh there's something called the
efficient market theory
which says that
there's nothing in the data
let's say price data
which will indicate anything about the
future because the price is sort of
always right the price is always right
in some sense
but that's just not true
so there are anomalies in the data even
in the price history data for one thing
uh
commodities especially
used to
trend uh not dramatically trend but
trend so if you could get the trend
right you'd bet on the trend and you'd
make money more often than you wouldn't
whether it was going down or going up
that was an anomaly
in the in the data but gradually we
found more and more
and more and more anomalies none of them
is so overwhelming that you're going to
clean up on a particular anomaly because
if they were other people would have
seen them so they have to be subtle
things and you put together
a collection of these
subtle anomalies and you begin to get
something that will predict pretty well
it's it's what's called machine learning
so you find
things
that are predictive
you might guess oh
such and such
should be predictive might be predictive
and you test it out in the computer and
maybe it isn't maybe it isn't what
discipline of mathematics or disciplines
is it multi-disciplinary or are we
talking it's mostly statistics
it's mostly statistics
and uh
some
uh
some probability theory
and
but i can't get into you know what
things we do do use and what things we
don't use we we
reach for different things that might
come that might be effective i would
imagine lots of people want to be
financially successful most most people
want that of course i suppose and lots
of people are good at mathematics and
know a lot about computers like you know
at your level i would imagine why did
you do it why didn't someone else do it
i don't know well first of all some
other people have done it
uh i think that we're
our firm is
better but nonetheless uh i'm pretty
sure of that but nonetheless other
people have done some very
good modeling and so we're not alone
but it's not easy to do
and there's a big
barrier to entry
for example
huge data sets that we've collected over
the years programs that we've written to
make it really easy to test hypotheses
and so on
the infrastructure is exceptionally good
so everything is tuned right it took
years to learn how to do that i know you
guys made the model so
you do have the ownership of it and feel
proud of it but is it hard to follow the
model
religiously like is it hard for your ego
to think all the successes because of
the computer like and i just i just sat
there and watched no the computer's just
a tool that we used to i mean it's uh
a good cabinet maker doesn't say it's
all because of my wonderful chisel you
know you may have great film equipment
but that's not why you're a success at
doing what you're doing you you're
working with good equipment but
another guy would make a mess of it with
the same equipment so
no we don't we don't feel
oh the computer is doing everything the
computer does what you tell it to do
given that you will put some of it down
to luck what are you more proud of
all of this in the business or the or
the mathematics
from that first half of your career oh
to the extent that i'm proud
i think i'm proud of both i i think
you know i've done some mathematics and
some but had a positive effect and i'm i
guess i'm proud of that
and i've built a nice business and i'm
proud of that i don't say i'm prouder of
one than the other and now for the last
number of years i've been working with
my wife on this foundation which she
started actually in 94
with my money but nonetheless she
started the foundation and then i joined
i got
more and more involved with the
foundation as
time went on and now that's my main
thing and i'm pretty proud of the
foundation let me focus your focus you
more on which the mathematics versus the
business then would you would you trade
any of your
any or all of your business success for
for being the man who cracked the
riemann hypothesis or something like
that right now that's a good question
when i trade that for
well i probably trade some of it i mean
for the riemann hypothesis
it would certainly uh
i guess be a thrill to to
solve three minute hypothesis i'm
pleased
mostly with what
with
the way my career has gone
uh
so
uh would i trade part of it for
something
i don't know it's i've never looked back
and said i wish
at least in business i wish i hadn't
done that or i wish i had done this and
not that whatever it is i've never
looked back that way
the foundation is focused
on support of scientific research
primarily basic science but not
completely because we have a large
autism project which
involves a lot of basic science but the
but
treatments are a goal but the rest is
support of mathematics physics computer
science
biology
of all sorts neuroscience genetics we
support basic science and uh
that is what we like to do there's a
certain amount of outreach we we have a
math for america pro we spend maybe
10 or 15 percent on uh outreach
outreach and education but uh 80 85
is uh
support of basically basic science you
put a lot of money into mathematics so
you're you've got some right to comment
on it how are you feeling about it oh i
think mathematics is is really uh going
quite well uh worldwide the research
then a bit a lot of new ideas are
coming up new fields
sort of are
are flourishing
it feels
like a pretty healthy enterprise to me
what's not healthy is the state of
mathematics education in our country
that's very unhealthy
uh for young people
that's why we have
we started this thing called math for
america and so on
but
we don't have enough teachers of
mathematics who know it
who know the subject
and even of science and and that's for a
simple reason
uh 30 40 years ago
if you knew some mathematics enough to
teach let's say in high school there
weren't a million other things you could
do with that knowledge oh yeah maybe you
could become a professor but let's
suppose you're not quite at that level
but you you're good at math and so on
being a math teacher was a nice job
but today if you know that much
mathematics
you can get a job at google you can get
a job at ibm you can get a job at
goldman sachs i mean there's plenty of
opportunities that are going to pay more
than being a high school teacher right
there weren't so many when i was going
to high school
such things so
the quality
of high school teachers in math has
declined
simply because
if you know enough to teach in high
school you know enough to work for
google and uh well they're not going to
pay that much in high school so how do
you
redress that how do we redress that as a
country
um
well
you have
so we work
a person works for a combination of
financial reward and respect
right so a guy becomes supreme court
justice
he's not doing it because he's going to
make a fortune uh
he'll be well paid i suppose but you
know supreme court justice everyone says
it's a big deal you have a lot of
respect and you respect yourself
presumably
uh
so
there are many so you
can't pay
let's say high school teachers of math
as much as they would get at google
but you can give them a bump
pay them more we we
give people fifteen thousand dollars a
year more than they
would make their regular salary but we
also create a community
of math and science teachers
which
they love and it makes them feel
important and they are important do you
give your money to basic research
because you feel somehow indebted to it
for your own success or do you do it
just out of like a belief or do you do
you feel like you're giving something
back to us to what gave something to you
that's an interesting question
i do it because it feels good i like
science
i like to see it flourish
i like to be around scientists i i like
to learn some new things and my wife
feels the same way she loves science
so uh
we're very happy to
to do this do i feel i'm giving back
not especially
uh
you know uh
i could give back in a lot of ways
there's a lot of things i could do
besides support science do you have a
favorite number seven
next question
do you have a favorite mathematician
well
archimedes and euler
are my current favorites
but maybe you met somebody
i'm very impressed with those two guys
thank you so much for so much of your
time
all right well this was kind of fun
you